we have a story here of a pro-euthanasia
activist who's been convicted in the
Netherlands of sending suicide kits to
1600 people this is the inevitable
outgrowth of materialism the belief that
freedom is simply a product of making
multiple choices and has nothing to do
with what the right or wrong choice is
as well as a person's virtuous
predispositions or lack thereof or what
man is meant to do and whether he's free
to flourish in the role that he was
built for rather than the one he has
chosen for himself irrationally the
activist Alex s was selling kits to
people who didn't qualify for the legal
assisted suicide program and according
to the court the activist convinced
people that the drugs were painless but
in reality they suffered quote severe
distress and panic which led to a
gruesome death but it actually gets even
worse than that in April the Netherlands
announced plans to expand the assisted
suicide and euthanasia program to allow
children ages 1 to 12 year olds to be
what eligible yeah what a a one-year-old
can opt for suicide medically he can't
his parents can what that's murder you
can't a one-year-old cannot opt in to
get themselves killed that's a parent
doing it to the kid yep yeah it's it's
sickening it's completely sickening this
is this is what my friend Mary
Harrington has referred to as the uh
this war on Imago day it's the idea that
the human body is sacred in any way
shape or form and you can't just exit it
or mutilate it at any time and what
we're seeing in relation to materialism
is it's either the body is a prison
um not everything is gnosticism people
you know get that get that out but but
the the the trans identity is a form of
gnosticism where your body is a fleshy
prison and you have to approximate it to
feel you truly are inside that's right
uh is true so there's no sacredness
about the body you were given you just
play mix and match with the appendages
until you feel okay or there's the
attitude that your body is kind of a
vessel of gratification it's just it's
just the means by which you feel around
in a purely sensory world and so when
you stop being capable of that sensation
when you stop being able to be pleasure
seeking because you have a terminal
illness or you're old or you're just
depressed and you don't feel anything
anymore then they say well it's
perfectly logically consistent to exit
and their only complaint is that you are
suffering not that you are achieving the
ultimate suffering which is just the
extinguishing of your conscience exactly
well okay that's a very important point
and I would frame it very similarly once
you have made the meaning of life
pleasure once a person is no longer able
to or as the very least less capable of
experiencing subjectively pleasurable
States then their life no longer has
meaning if the purpose of life of the
meaning of life goes deeper than your
own particular emotions about the
situation that you're in then no amount
of suffering actually justifies ending
the life of a human being directly and
intentionally yeah this is classic
Sultan it's an existentialism this is
and then if you ever want to sort of
Escape
um I've suffered with depressional
throughout my life I'm not going to
minimize it but if you ever want to get
perspective read the accounts of the
people that have suffered the most and
you will probably never suffer and they
have come through it with sincere
metaphysical convictions and faith in
humanity Victor frankels brought about
this that Soldier Nixon's written about
this if they can survive a gulag or a
concentration camp you can survive not
being able to access PornHub in your
stickers
and Utah blocked it because kids weren't
able to look at it what an important
detail in that story and but before
before I passed you and I just want to
mention here uh with what you just said
um I agree with you that when you look
at people who have experienced the most
tremendous suffering they they tend to
be deferential to a higher power they
believe in Morality they believe in
meaning and of course that's because
experience is an expensive classroom and
those who have paid the greatest Price
often have the greatest knowledge but
also because I believe those situations
actually select for people who have a
deeper view of what existence is that
goes beyond pleasure because if you
don't view that to begin with or you
don't come to believe that at some point
through that experience you're just
gonna it's a crucible for Spiritual
formation yeah well being in the gym man
with a personal trainer being like
you're 12 more 12 more reps now we're
going up wait now we're going 25 pounds
that's like hell it's like being in a
kind of personal hell for a moment just
a moment but after coming out of it it's
like I don't want to kill myself anymore
I've already been through it man God is
good like this life is great
is why MSNBC came out the other day and
said lifting weights is right wing
because you're an independent thinker
the once you once you master your own
body you're not contingent on other
people's stimulants or or Pleasures to
try and sedate that screaming conscience
then then the the universal homogeneous
State can't have you in their clutches
sure man yeah I gotta get way more right
wing I'll have to hit the gym
one point that you mentioned here is
it's like your own personal hell there's
something here and there's actually
something that touches such an important
part no no I know but but this this
touch is on an important part of like
the Christian tradition which is dying
to yourself it's like to describe it as
hell in some senses describe it as like
a small death like you are willfully
embracing a form of death but what is
the outcome of that a resurrection your
muscles get stronger you actually
strengthen yourself because you
willfully embraced that small death
literally tearing your muscles bleeding
on the inside so that it can forge and
regrow stronger and bigger yeah that
small death has like led to a small
Resurrection in a sense and I think I
think we see that with with uh all
productive things that are painful right
if if you really buckled down and do
your job even though it's difficult
there's like a small death you feel oh
it's so beautiful outside I don't want
to work right now but then when all is
said and done and you've created this
it's like this moment of Resurrection
you've created something beautiful
because you willingly Embrace that yeah
I think there's a resistance to
accepting that Gloria comes through
struggle right yeah yeah is through a
lot of things and there's a fear of
hardship right so when we talk about
censoring people's language or saying
you know you have to call me by these
things you need to you need to make me
feel good about myself we are
encouraging a culture that is avoiding
Challenge and avoiding personal growth
through Challenge and I think that is
what's most devastating to uh to people
today is that you can never feel true
satisfaction without really feeling
you've achieved something and sometimes
achievement comes at a cost I won't I
agree with you I think you can't
minimize you know how how crippling
depression anxiety some of the emotional
states that people go through can be on
the other hand uh working through your
struggle is ultimately how you become a
better and stronger person version of
yourself and it gives you a perspective
effective that you are I personally feel
like meant to have right you you want to
have insight into the world that makes
you more in touch with The Human
Condition I think about meditation
that's another struggle because it's
easy to think it's easy to get
distracted and think about the colors
you see or the noise you're hearing but
to have no thoughts that's a challenge
and it is hard that's why prayer is a
lot easier because all you do is
externalize your thoughts and you give
it up to the big man upstairs and he can
walk you through it rather than try and
force yourself to be completely blind
you just bend your conscience out and
you actually have a dialogue with
someone that can help you out but and
there's also I would say there's also a
discipline and difficulty to prayer uh
which is kind of touching on on part of
what you're saying which is even though
I don't like recommend the form of
meditation you're describing I agree
that there's something very difficult
about not just allowing your internal
monologue to drag you everywhere without
taking a moment to reflect about what
you're thinking about what you're
orienting yourself towards it's really
important uh I believe to develop a
prayer life in part to escape that just
constantly being led around by that that
almost nagging that like very ADHD jump
from subject to subject to subject is
based on whatever interests why I don't
pray what I Don't Pray by saying things
in my thoughts I just have no thoughts
is because I feel like it's polarizing
to choose this is what it's going to be
like with no thought there's no I'm not
deciding it's got to be this now I I get
concerned about my polarizing my
behavior in my mind that's interesting
so so here's what I would say
um
when you're allowing yourself and we all
do this right and this is what we're
trying to escape in some sense when we
allow ourselves to just be dragged
around from thought to thought in that
instance we're actually not choosing
what we're thinking about right we're
just being led and I think to jump to
another state where you're trying to
suppress all thought I would say you're
also just not choosing a particular
thought and so that's why I would say
like prayer is actually
um the opposite of just letting yourself
being led around and it does require
choice but but um your thoughts being
dragged everywhere doesn't require a
choice right you're just kind of letting
it happen but it gets to a point where
you're not suppressing the thoughts
anymore they just stop coming into your
head and it'll be like 40 minutes will
go you'll be like five seconds and then
you realize you're thinking you're like
okay let it go no thought and then like
some time goes by and you're like oh oh
there's a oh I was thinking for a few
minutes or a few seconds okay let it go
and then all of a sudden it's like
longer eight seconds then it's like 20
seconds you have no thought then all of
a sudden you can do it for five minutes
and you're like whoa then like all your
emotions they're back to Baseline yeah
well it's it's interesting we'll have to
discuss it because again I've made my
thoughts about like that form of
meditation station clear but it'd be a
cool discussion for the after show too I
think to get into some of that stuff uh
and then with reference to what uh
Hannah Claire was saying about making
yourself better I just want to mention
this before we move on from the topic
you made this point becoming a stronger
better version of yourself if you
believe that there is a Telus that there
is a purpose that there is a reason you
are here than achieving that purpose is
what you're supposed to do and a
struggle is something that you may have
to embrace in order to reach that
fulfillment to in order to fulfill your
purpose uh and you can get pleasure from
that like of course naturally there's a
natural pleasure that comes from doing
things the right way and when you
develop virtue there's like a pleasure
that a person can get from doing
something virtuous that said I think the
modern conceptualization which is just
feel good about things of course can't
contend with that and what ends up
happening is your your mission is not
necessarily become a better version of
yourself it's just that maximize
positive experiences and minimize uh
displeasurable experiences and so what
that results in is basically a
philosophy that I don't think can argue
against the best possible state to be in
is a simulation where everything goes
well for you and not living in the real
world doing difficult but important
things where you get whatever you want
because it's completely about
self-indulgence and in that you are
never able to experience true Joy or
happiness because it's all about
momentary immediate pleasure right I
mean some of the challenges that we're
talking about like when you bring up
working out is that long term you're
going to feel the benefits of it it's
not that every single day when you're
lifting weights is super fun right
you're exhausted you're tired it's that
ultimately these things are worth it and
that you stay on the path because you
know you're achieving something great
through the sacrifice and struggle that
it takes I do like yesterday I was
playing Drops of Jupiter by Train on and
I start crying man I think about my mom
and he's singing about his mom in that
song and she died I guess and her Soul's
out there and it comes it's just like
but then I feel like it's like yeah it
hurts and it's painful it's sad but then
I'm normal like um it's okay it's okay
you don't have to put you can bear Xanax
in your in your brain yeah yeah yeah I
know that's an interesting point too
like trying to get through things
without medicating yourself but also not
to get addicted to the pain because it
can become like the crying I was like I
want to I couldn't keep doing it I'm
like oh I feel and I want them like no
just breathe and kind of let it out you
know it comes you know you don't force
it onto yourself just happens yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time